how are you I'm look at you in New York
incredible you're like glowing Do You
Love New York do you love being here I
love I'm only really ever here when I do
a show so so I'll live here for months
on end yeah it's got that's living here
though but it's only sort of every 10
years that I end up Broadway but when
I'm here uh I love it yeah did you grow
up doing theater is that why you love it
so yeah yeah I was I think I was 28
before I had a television audition it
was all theater through my teens and my
20s I love hearing that though for
actors that are still like pushing and
they're like man I'm 28 like I haven't
hit how I want to yet like I love
hearing that and you're this huge TV
star like you just never know like
timing it came like and back then sort
of I was hitting I was just getting into
television in my about to be 30 and it
was subtly too old I playing dads in my
first yeah so it's awesome I heard that
you got to do this and I've never seen
Elton John live and I'm so jealous but
you got to I haven't I was poor growing
up man and then by the time I made money
I'm so busy I only catch shows like when
I can but Elton is incredible and I
heard that you were at his final concert
here in North America well so one of my
a story I love to tell when I was doing
theater in high school I was doing a
production of God spell in 11th grade
and one of my co-stars was David fernish
who is now Elton John's husband so we've
had a relationship through our lives and
I've had one with Elton that uh see I
don't know 10 12 times I've seen Elton
over the years oh my God you lucky man I
know it's so great it's also allowed for
some crazy friendships like the people I
got to meet uh through that period of
time
I you know I lot of actors look up to
other actors I was in just in awe of
musicians always I when I was 15 I just
wanted to be you I want to be a rock
star yeah I want to that's funny because
my favorites are actors that sing we're
we're shallow and empty I would I
wouldn't I wouldn't worry about but but
so I want I just so I loved Elton and I
love and I I got to meet Bernie toppen
who writes all of elton's lyrics and we
became friends Through The Years great
writer and uh I wanted to show this I I
was
invited yeah yeah so so uh this this is
Bernie toph's uh 70th birthday party
there's Bernie Elton Alice Cooper and me
and I based this Photograph on this
photograph which is from 1972 I think
Alice needed you needed to undo your
shirt a little bit more give some more
chest hair you recogize who that is
between Alice and Elton is uh Paul Lind
from the Hollywood Squares so uh so I
I'm Paul Lind in uh in 200 whatever that
was next time just gold chain more ha
yes yeah I mean so I mean when I'm 15
I'm in my bedroom pretending to be Alice
Cooper like I this was that that was how
how I became an actor was wanting to be
a rock star isn't it funny though I find
that the people because I met him years
ago aliceon he was so nice like so sweet
and he's like this huge rock star with
goth makeup and like all a sudden I was
like I was kind of afraid to meet him
but he's so nice so nice and it was it's
all a character but it's a character
that I still do at Halloween
occasionally yeah he's just well it's a
great one it's the classic um so what
did you listen to music as a kid you
listen to Alice it was that Queen was my
big one oh Freddy M uh and so and my my
father loved when I'd put on you know
tights in my bedroom and and and
uh says I'd go downstairs to get
something from the kitchen he was like
you stay in your room in God but yeah it
was I that's who I wanted to be very
much by the way you're my son my
seven-year-old son is like he looks like
a little it's like Harry Styles is that
generation now like you know cuz he
wardrobe is so like eclectic and I love
it that Harry is like a representative
for him because he's also talented but
he also dresses like so fun and
eccentric you know a bit and my son
feels comfortable and he's seven and
that's so awesome because you know
sometimes they're always like boys can't
do that and I always look at I'm like
boys can do anything they want you know
and and my my son's 21 in college and
it's this is the time to be in college
is uh is just the experimentation yeah
you never know well what was your first
concert very first um I I love to say
that it was was Queen but that that was
really my second in 78 my first was uh
ELO and and me meatloaf opened for them
I actually loved meatloaf Bo yes I would
do anything I loved it it was so it was
very operatic gr yeah well that first
album hasn't wasn't even out yet that's
Paradise by the Dashboard Light and all
that stuff hadn't really dropped which
is why they were an opening band but
they were an opening band in front of
70,000 people oh my God and there's you
know the he's little he's that big yeah
uh on stage but that album oh my gosh
that's a that's a great first concert I
can't I can't remember M was out there
AOS Smith or Selen Deion which are very
different I yeah very passionate both
but yeah I saw Errol Smith too in like
70 I think it was 78 79 oh man that was
that changed my I we were going to get
married yeah you would seen him yeah I
was yeah was he aware of it no but he
but he would love me yeah no I I went to
the concer and I just I love that
feeling that you get inspired by people
that's how I get by actors by the way
because it's such a different world from
for me like but it's but I get that with
certain musicians as well and just
seeing him you know like with the fan
and the and everything I just yeah I
would pretend I was Stephen Tyler that
whole s thing that he used to I mean he
can still do it but but wow what he was
doing in 73 yeah was like nuts we did a
photo shoot though later in life and
have you ever met like one of your
Heroes and it was like he was so like
passionate that he was it my dream was
for him to go on my face but then when
he was actually doing it I was
like I was like so funny F and I just
got so nervous I was overwhelmed with
passion deep inside so you're back on
Broadway this is called the cottage
right the cottage which is your your
classic English sex farce okay uh
and it's hysterical although it is there
I am there um but is that
much it's actually it's a new play
written by a young American woman but
she just wanted to write in the classic
sort of null coward style so it's very
it's oldfashioned uh but it's more from
the fem perspective it's like a feminist
snow cowy black but it's dirty as hell
and uh I would love it love it come
that's amazing are you working with
Laura Bell Bundy yes yeah yeah i' I've
run into her a couple times Laura Bell
is a pro she was Legally Blonde the
musical she was Tony nominated and she
we are we are such a team at the top of
that show I just couldn't do it without
her it's so funny now all I'm seeing is
Freddy Mercury when I think at you right
now like like I you were literally
talking and I was like listen listen
listen I was like I can't now I'm just
picturing you in a movie playing Freddy
Mercury so I have a question so whenever
an actor directs you like Jason
Alexander who directs this like is that
different than when it's it's not an
actor do they Direct in a different way
most actors love other actors directing
them for the most part uh I love it
because Jason and I are are old friends
not from NBC or whatever but from being
dads at the same
school our yeah yeah so that was and he
directed me in production of the
Fantastics 11 years ago so we had a
great Shand
and as as a as a comedy Legend I mean I
was just so so it's so great this is a
really freaking funny comedy it's got to
be good too to like work with your
friends like that's why I I'm at the age
of now to where I'm just like I just
want to work with people like I love to
work with and I just want to do it you
know at the same time I've always loved
meeting new people having new cast and I
got to I just got to talk about the cast
of The Cottage for one second they are
all Broadway Pros they are amazing and
particularly my friend Dana steingold
who is a huge Kelly Clarkson fan great
and I just said name I just said it on
television there you go Dan so what is
your favorite do you like acting on
stage like that or do you like acting
like on TV because my this is everybody
always ask me to act and I got I hate
acting on TV or movie anything like that
I hate because I don't like I like the
constant stream because I grew up in
like musical theater I like the stage
acting better it's said what are you I
yeah I mean I I if I did it all the time
perhaps I you're in for a little of it
but I I love being on stage I miss it
and I'm hoping to do a little bit
breaking up the manani is cool though
was what was your Musical that you did
in high school I did a few but the one
that I felt like I finally was like oh
man I could do this for a living was I
was um Seven Brides Seven Brothers oh
wow that so I was like I was it was like
and it was double cast and so that was
that's a lot of brides in a lot yeah
yeah well there's a political backstory
to that that I'll save for off camera
but no we were and we only got one show
and we learned all of it so like I was
like yeah the other cast got more but
anyway but but it was like incredible
though to that moment do you remember
that moment you're on stage it was that
I was singing one man and that and I was
like I just I felt this like
overwhelming like purpose and it it was
magical 100% for me that production of
God spell I was talking about it wasn't
even the the evening performances that
we eventually did it was that assembly
where they bring the school together and
they do a thing for the football team
whatever like and now they're going to
theater class is going to do a song from
the new show God spell and it was that
it was being Jesus in the in the
rainbowers and Pi who had never much car
for me you know but suddenly now was
like oh okay we get it I was like this
is it Wait So speaking of friends coming
to a show I always tell people to never
tell me if someone comes to a show yeah
I hate knowing do you like KN I like
know in a long run like this where
you're doing the same show we've done it
110 times now um it helps me to see it
through new eyes I can get excited
because I know so and so's out there and
and they're English so they'll hate my
accent or or they're or judging or
really judge you so they'll they'll hate
the whole show but oh man I get that
makes me ner I don't get nervous on
stage but when I know that friends or
family or something it's I'm like I
don't want to know yeah I don't know why
get getes me a gives me a little kick so
one time speaking of that though you
actually surprised Shawn Hayes right was
in Chicago yeah so Sean if I don't know
if you got a chance to see good night
oscar but he won the Tony for it he so
talented he's so incredible but um
that's there's us together but he uh uh
he did it in Chicago first and I knew he
was doing it he was very ke this is like
a year and a half ago but I flew in to
see him and surprise him and I told him
that night you're going to New York
right he said yeah hopefully and I said
yeah you're G to win the Tony oh my God
you you're like Nostradamus predicted
that it was pretty clear he was pretty
yeah he's so talented so have you um
ever had like huge mistakes on stage
like like because it's live stop this
show a lot we have a lot of prop things
go wrong which leads to a lot of improv
and and funny but I haven't had terrible
mistake the one I always tell is cuz
it's it was the beginning of my career I
had a I had a sort of a standing over
there with a spear part in a production
of King leer giant production in Canada
at the Stratford Festival and one night
I was just at the fire in the center of
the stage and Leo is talking and I know
something bad's going to happen I feel
sick I got to go but I don't I keep
waiting and I keep waiting it's a long
scene and finally I turned to go and I
fainted dead away and my helmet bounced
into the audience and my sphar fell down
somebody and Lear apparently went uh
uh bear him hence and and so somebody
picked me up and then took me off and I
I sort of came to at the stage door and
and he hovered over me he'd finished the
scene and he came and he said are you
all right dear boy oh my God
he that's amazing yes and he
went you me so note to self don't faint
but that's what I love about stage
that's what is every night is different
it could be the same play Same musical
but there's things happen and I love
that the energy of that I think that's
pretty magical we've had a thing we do
in this show that I came up with in
rehearsal where I'm trying to get rid of
a of a daming bazer that is going to
give me away and I throw it into the
audience and um like a rockstar you are
Freddy Mercury and then what I whatever
I do with the person that catches it is
is fun but once in a while the person
has thrown it back on stage which I love
cuz then you can make stuff out yeah
it's pretty fun yeah then you're like a
comedian on stage I love that well I
love your
well let's take another break you can
see Eric in the cottage on Broadway at
the Hayes Theater now through October
29th and his podcast Just Jack and will
with Shan Hayes and Eric McCormack is
available wherever you get your podcast
or like to
[Music]
[Applause]
listen thank you guys y'all have a great
night guys I'm going
home